[Music]
not everyone is meant to make a
difference
but for me
the choice to live an ordinary life
is no longer an option
he saved my life twice and i've never
even seen his face
you are
amazing
i believe there's a hero in all of us
gives us strength makes us noble
even though sometimes we have to give up
the thing we want the most
where are you i'm looking for you all
morning you're late always late you're
fired look at your meter your grades
have been declining you always appear
exhausted
i know i'm trying
where you been pal you don't return my
calls i've been kind of busy taking
pictures of your friend spiderman killed
my father
no matter what i do
do you love me or not
no matter how hard i try i want
spiderman dead it's the ones i love who
will always be the ones who pay i can't
keep thinking about you i'm getting
married i want a life of my own
i'm spider-man
no more
you look different i let things get in
the way before there was something i
thought i had to do i don't have to i
like seeing you tonight peter
now on to the main event
octavius is going to put oscorp on the
map in a way my father never even
dreamed
crazy scientist turns himself into some
kind of a monster four mechanical arms
welded right onto his body
you take spider-man's pictures where is
he
sticking off your loyalty to
[Music]
there are bigger things happening here
than me and you
[Music]
let's see who's behind the mask
[Music]
i'm gonna ask mj to marry me a man has
to put his wife before himself can you
do that peter yeah
i think i can
we have some new information this is
your uncle's actual killer we lost his
trail two days ago
this man killed my uncle and he's still
out there
everybody needs help sometimes peter
even spider-man
revenge is like a
poison that can take us over
before you know it
can turn you into something ugly
the suit where'd this come from
the power
feels good
you lose yourself to it
whoa spidey love the new outfit
remember ben parker what does it matter
to you anyway everything
do you want to push me away why would i
want to push you away i love you
you knew this was coming i didn't kill
your father
what's happened to you
[Music]
we've all done terrible things to each
other we have to forgive each other or
everything we ever wear will mean
nothing
i need your help
i have to stop it
[Music]
this could be the end of spiderman
how did you get out there fire escape
it's 20 stories doorman's intimidating
tell us a little bit about yourself mr
parker
not much to tell really peter lives with
his aunt and uncle
did you catch that spider guy yet no but
we will this guy wears a mask like an
outlaw i think he's trying to do
something maybe the police can't can't
you know if you're gonna steal cars
don't dress like a car thief you a cop
you seriously think i'm a cop in a
skin-tight red and blue suit
who are you
i know it's been rough for you peter
i forgot all about that thing it was
your dad's
your father was a very secretive man
peter dr cutters i'm richard parker's
son
your father and i were gonna change the
lives of millions including mine
extraordinary how did you come up with
this
there's a rumor of a new species in new
york
it can be aggressive if threatened
[Music]
i gotta stop him because i created
him that's not your job
maybe it is
38th of new york's finest versus one guy
in a unitard
wow
if you want the truth peter
come and get it
i am issuing an arrest warrant
for the masked vigilante known as
spiderman
every day i wake up knowing
that the more people i try to save
the more enemies i will make
and it's just a matter of time
before i face those with more power
than i can
overcome i'm so sorry i'm late
i had a traffic thing did your traffic
jam have anything to do with being i
don't know shot at by machine guns
yeah yeah i was implied i was implying
that
he's a parker mary i was born you're
gonna want to see this
oscar get you under surveillance
why isn't that the question of the day
there's something you're not telling me
anthony
i once told you that
secrets have a cost
the truth does too
my name is richard parker i have
discovered what oscorp was going to use
my research for i have a responsibility
to protect the world from what i know
they're capable of
the future
we
literally
can change the world
what about peter not everyone has a
happy ending
this is bigger than you peter
i made a choice
mercy
[Music]
without spiderman
finally here we go good evening peter
you have 576 possible web shooter
combinations that is awesome
i can keep that suit yeah it doesn't fit
me when's your next retreat what next
mission we'll call you all right
that's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
toe for you i'm not there yet all right
kid good luck out there
hey peter you coming tonight i can
tonight i got the stark internship
what's up guys
mr here's my report for tonight i
stopped the grand theft bicycle hey
could you do me a favor hold on to that
does anybody fight oh i helped this old
lady and she bought me a churro so
that was nice
i just feel like i could be doing more
wait a minute you guys aren't the real
avengers hulk gives it away
new move i'm working on not bad
god this feels so strange
his weapons are crazy dangerous listen
peter there are people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spiderman
the world's changing boys it's time we
change too
this is my chance to prove myself we
have a spanish quiz
you gotta get better at this part of the
job i don't understand
i'm
hey where you intimidated
what are you hiding peter
[Music]
i'm just kidding i'm here bye
there's a ton of other subsystems in
here but they're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol you're sick of
mr stark treating me like a kid but you
are a kid yeah peter can stop a bus with
his bare hands
my name is peter parker i'm pretty sure
you know the rest
i saved the city fell in love then i
saved the city again and again and again
look i'm a comic book a cereal i get a
christmas album and a so-so popsicle but
this isn't about me
not anymore
spider-man swings in once a day zip zaps
up in his little mask and answers to no
one i love you minds i know
[Music]
dad
i love you that's a copy
ladies and gentlemen my name is miles
morales
i'm the one and only spider-man
at least that's what i thought you ever
hear from super collider you're gonna
love this dimension
now
you're like me that's
impossible all right kid listen up this
frog is your universe it's soggy it's
weird it's gross and this delicious
normal fry is my universe
so you want to learn to be spiderman can
you teach me yes i can't time to swing
good you're doing it double tap to
release and whip it out again okay swift
and release your natural square
hey guys who are you i'm gwen stacy
i'm from another another dimension how
many more spider people are there hey
fellas
hello
this could literally not get any weirder
it can get weirder
okay
we need to get back to our universes
soon brooklyn is going to collapse my
family lives in brooklyn
miles what's wrong
this was never your city
[Music]
it's mine
if i don't destroy the collider none of
us will have a home to go home too
remember what makes you different
is what makes you spiderman
officer i love you
wait what
[Music]
do animals talk in this dimension
because i don't want to freak him out
[Music]
[Applause]
everywhere i go i see his face
i just really miss him
yeah i miss him too
[Music]
i don't think tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
going to be here after he was gone
you gonna be the next iron man now well
no i don't have time i'm too busy doing
your jobs oh i'm kidding i'm kidding
look keep up the good work because i am
going on vacation
[Music]
heads up nick fury's calling you
i don't really want to talk to [ __ ]
why because if you don't talk to them
and i have to talk i want to talk to
them
you sent nick fury to voicemail i got to
go you do not ghost nick fury what up
dorks what's up we're just talking about
this trip i'm here in saint marco polos
oh i think mj really likes me everyone's
been when i first fell alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact spiderman
this is mr beck
you could use someone like you on my
world new world back is from earth just
not ours the snap to our hole in our
dimension
you're saying there's a multiverse we
have a job to do
you're coming with us
[Music]
there's got to be someone else you can
use what about thor off world captain
marvel unavailable
but i'm just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[Music]
[ __ ] please you've been to space
what do you want peter
i want to go back on my trip with the
girl who i really like and tell her how
i feel mj i am spider-man
no of course i'm not
i mean it's
kind of obvious
you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility saving the
world requires sacrifices
sometimes people die
oh my god
just always feel like i'm putting my
friends in danger
the world needs the next iron man
you're going to step up or not
[Music]
i gotta get you guys out of here get on
the jet who are you i work with
spider-man you work for spider-man i
work with spider-man not for spider-man
new plan
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
like how do you tell someone that you're
spiderman
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please we saved half the
universe together i think we're beyond
you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj is going to forget about
everything we've ever been through stop
tampering with the spell oh my god ned
he's my best friend my aunt may should
really stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
[Music]
you